uh well we will just remind you what has  just happened  do i seem rattled was the question he  put so he was pulled out of this news  conference  because there was a shooting on the  outside of the white house premises  they just wanted me to step aside but it  was just one person  that person now being taken to hospital  the president understand that they were  armed uh they were shot by secret  service service or law enforcement  people  and there are some terrific looking  people ready to go he said if  something was necessary talking about  the security outside the white house so  let's just  remind ourselves of what happened a  little earlier  going to be i mean the way they're going  it looks like they're just about going  to be topping records hopefully soon  excuse me  you